recap the throgs days I feel hey
youtubers here's some game thrones
telltale gameplay too sweet you pumped
for the behind-the-scenes special that's
happening tonight don't forget walking
dead is happening first at six pm and
then the game of thrones special is
gonna be at seven thirty p.m. so i'll be
doing the videos in that order so Game
of Thrones might not post till Monday
morning i'll be uploading the rest of
this gameplay to my game channel Charlie
streams there's a link for that in the
descriptions you guys don't know where
it is now Duncan who I've decided to
name you as my Sentinel I'm just worried
about my family the king was not
inclined to offer help for your family
are you willing to risk an alliance with
the ground it's a risk I'm willing to
take Lord Tyrion your mother asked me to
cross the Narrow Sea to find your
brother crashing we don't want white
hilt men within these walls you can be
my highborn ward my lord if you want a
hostage take me that's not good
All Right see what's going on ah marine
I finally get some tanaris sneaky
scorpion so this is three days after the
beginning of season for the liberation
is an heiress is liberation it's just me
bershka took you long enough hey rails
getting warm boer war man i should say
you can stop pacing they'll be here soon
hooker yikes best place could use a good
cleaning I complain to the owner except
he's probably dead I'll goes in yellow
comes out yellow waste time even
drinking it you asked me considering we
found it in an abundant oven it's not
bad they smell off to you it's the only
thing in yunkai that doesn't I know it's
a filthy haven for thieves murderers and
other deadly bastards you should feel
right at home I know I do may we drink
feve and fight until the end I'll drink
to that you drink to anything another
round
maybe they'll just start punching each
other and have sex Klingon style have
you forgotten about our honored and
exalted guests go see if he's still
breathing hello
how's he doing mm-hmm we need him alive
collectors bounty after that no those
ashes gay hmm you should see him when
he's angry 800 gold dragons for
capturing him lucky we caught him trying
to flee young Kai lucky for us not so
lucky for him we should find more former
slave masters with bounties on their
head don't need any more naked fat men
in my life thank you Oh see maybe this
isn't yeah I neither porner had to
really spend money will buy the finest
wines the best [ __ ] sleep in a bed
without fleas sounds nice doesn't it i
onlys the best oz when the bad ones are
so much more fun yikes I knew I liked
you for a reason my point is with enough
coin we could do anything go anywhere I
could afford passage back to Westeros do
I am rough but nothing from my family in
years you mean go home they treated you
like [ __ ] they're kicked you out because
you fell in love with a girl from the
wrong damn house Quinn a man doesn't
chew to he loves your family should
understand that that's all very Catholic
rato sin it's bloody houses who [ __ ]
cares they're still my family our
brothers and sisters they had nothing to
do with it I suppose that's true just
remember we have a good thing here and
any moment now we're gonna be rich
let's make a toast to all of us deadly
bastards it's a war I to us
if the screams laggy just turned the
quality down to like 720p biscuit I
thought freed slaves put the bounty on
bizzack they did with his own gold so
why are the [ __ ] lost legion here
that is all from the volantis job maybe
he's forgotten about that you I told you
if I saw your diesel isn't it funny how
life brings old friends together I cut
your [ __ ] throats it's good to see
you too to Zell well is he where's who
here 400 dragons they must be working
for the wise masters and that's all
you're getting the bounty is a torn you
get for it's more than you deserve yeah
this is yan kai the wise masters live in
yunk I are there based on Yan Kai wait
for season 5 800 I'm thinking of it
don't be an [ __ ] now we're all sell
swords here we are nothing like you The
Lost Legion other blood of old Valyria
and we are done taking orders from
whimpering pigs and we're done with you
too but our DD so bossy do a B me you
just made a huge mistake to sell you are
going to be useful to me for once not
bloody likely the wise masters will hear
how Asha Forrester kidnapped the
venerable bezeq how he wouldn't take
less than eight hundred gold dragons so
he killed this I can stay luckily we
were there to deliver swift justice see
you steal the money and we get the blame
or they'll see us or just me know me sha
tsui kick ass
all right give that now no lie here's
one come on each it sheep good it'll
bust me cookie though this is for
volunteer sir
[ __ ] you wash fazal Costas will spill
you poorness ahhh the OL this reminds me
of that brothel and nervous you'll kill
me hey we're back to Westeros anyway the
song
yeah [ __ ] all the gods are firing oh
who the [ __ ] is he my uncle that's a f
bombs being dropped nothing did well
more on their way we need to go you wake
come on Malcolm damn that's given
Malcolm stop Asha I'm glad I found you
my god it's been far too long what are
you doing here your brother even sent me
I'm here to bring you home
hello
if the streams laggy I just recommend
turning the quality settings down you
can you can turn it all the way down to
like 360p you just met you might have
felt like cricket to like 1080p
everybody pumped about season five
there's actually the behind-the-scenes
special is this Sunday it's at seven
thirty p.m. eastern time so walking dead
also comes back on Sunday too so busy
day tomorrow and I have like a super
special project that I'm working on
later today I can't I can't post it till
tuesday though
you